how do you prevent big companies from
stealing your idea this is a question
that comes up a lot it's a question that
came from of my youtube viewers I am
greater who wrote in to say I'm creating
an app what happens when you release
your app other big companies have
hundreds thousands of developers will
steal your idea have the money to
advertise it how to prevent big
companies from stealing my idea and
making money off it more than I do so
here's the thing ok an idea an idea is
not enough the only way to save an idea
is through a patent ok if you have an
idea that you can patent then go get
your patent and the company's a big
companies if they want to use it then
they have to license your patent or buy
your patent from you that's the only way
to protect an idea otherwise what you
need to do is get out there and build
more than idea having idea is not enough
you got to go and create something and
here's what usually happens ok remember
big companies are slow typically they're
not the leaders in anything they're
typically very slow you could stay under
the radar for a long time before the big
companies notice and when a company is
looking at what you do they're going to
think either I'm going to reverse
engineer this or I'm going to buy the
company and this is your chance to get
sold I know because I sold to a big
company I had a biotech software company
ok
I had a biotech software company it was
a small business at the start of three
of us who were who are owners in the
company I built it up and I got to the
point with the business where companies
started coming to us they started coming
in and say we're interested in what
you're doing and these were big
companies and I had a choice to either
sell to them or I would face competition
from them and what they think this is
how their minds think ok they want to
get into my space ok this is going to be
the same for you they want to get into
your space with the app it's going to
take them time and money it's going to
take them time and money to develop the
app develop the software
or to also build up a community so when
the company bought my business they were
not just buying the software right they
could have redeveloped my software it
could have been I don't know how long
we're taking to do it but it would have
taken time it's not like they could do
this overnight but it was also the
market chair the user base people were
using our software and so by acquiring
your business they get in faster they
don't have to spend money developing the
software and they have a user base who
already loves what it is so if you want
to sell your idea sell your app then the
two things you need to do is one make it
great so have it have a technology lead
so that it can't just be reproduced in a
day and to build up an audience because
either they have the technology it
doesn't matter because you have the
audience so to summarize if you just
have an idea the only way to protective
is a patent if you can't get a patent
your idea is not protected but it
doesn't matter yet because you need to
prove this concept and if you have great
technology and a user base who loves
what you're doing you become a prime
candidate to be acquired sell your
business and move on to your next app
believe those are watching like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
makes you want to do more for you and
leave a comment let me know you think
you have a question leave it below like
video response thank you so much and
I'll see you soon